I want you to pay attention to how this
native button element reacts when it
receives input from different devices.
When I go and click on it with a mouse,
you'll notice that I don't see a focus
ring, but when I press the tab key,
I do see a focus ring.
Now let's check out a custom button
that I've created using a focus style.
Notice that when I go and
click on the button with a mouse,
both the focus style and the focus ring
are applied, and they stick around.
So what's going on here?
Why does my custom button not
work like the native button?
Well for native elements like button,
browsers implement special behaviors to
let them differentiate between mouse and
keyboard focus and they only display
the focus ring for keyboard focus.
The thinking being that mouse
users are less likely to need
the focus ring since they know
what they just clicked on.
Now unfortunately that same trick does
not apply to custom controls
you create yourself.
Because I've added a tab index to this
element, it means that regardless of how
it gained focus,
that ring will always be displayed.
And because I've used a focused
pseudo class style on it,
that style will also be displayed,
regardless of whether this gained
focused through a keyboard or a mouse.
Now, I should point out that as
of the time of this recording,
this behavior I'm describing varies
by the different browsers, so
it's not even consistent when and
where you'll see focused rings and
focused dials once you start
applying them in your application.
So this is actually pretty
frustrating for web developers.
Unfortunately, there isn't
currently any single cross-browser
solution that will let us differentiate
between mouse and keyboard focus.
In Firefox,
the moz-focusring CSS pseudoclass does
allow you to write a focus style that
will only be applied if the element
is focused via the keyboard.
So for instance, I can go in and click
on this custom button and I won't see
anything, but when I press tab, I see
the focus states that I would expect.
Now while the pseudoclass is
currently only supported in Firefox,
there is currently work going on to
add it to other browsers, like Chrome.
So who knows,
by the time you're watching this,
maybe it will have shipped and this will
be a much easier problem to work around.
Similarly, Alice and Brian Kardell have
written a great article exploring this
topic in more detail, and their article
also contains a JavaScript shim for
differentiating between mouse and
keyboard input.
You can use this shim today in your
applications to split things up, and
in the future roll in the focus
ring pseudoclass when it has
more widespread browser support.